[Music]
welcome to the pretty intense podcast
please hit subscribe 's right on time
because today I have Karen Anderson who
is a pet medium she's an author she's
written a few books she is an animal
Communicator as well as a pet loss
specialist so I asked her all things
animals all things like what happens
when they die and do they how do they
communicate with us and what about
euthanizing and food and crates and
cages and leashes and all kinds of
things being gone at work your energy
how they mirror you if you have an
animal you must listen the takeaways are
are super clear and super pure and I
even got a little emotional in this one
so if you want to know how to push my
buttons you just get into the animal
world with me really grateful for this
one and I hope it brings you as much
comfort as I found in the information so
thank you so much please enjoy if you've
been following me a while you know that
I've been drinking ag1 all year no
matter where I go or what I do if I'm at
the racetrack if I'm in Europe for 6
weeks no matter what I'm drinking ag1
every single morning when I started
drinking ag1 daily what I noticed was
that my gut health improved I could eat
so many different foods without it
bothering me my skin has gotten better
my hair is healthier so many functions
that everybody wants to get better got
better it's so awesome and I've been
bragging about it so much that my
friends and my family have also started
taking it and they love it as well ag1
is the supplement that I trust to
support my body's daily needs and that's
why we have been partners for so long if
you want to take ownership of your
health it starts with ag1 try ag1 and
get a free one-year supply of vitamin D3
K2 plus five free ag1 travel packs with
your first purchase go to drink ag1
/pret intense that's drink a1.com pretty
intense check it out I was so excited to
do this and I I prep for every guest and
I I read a lot and watch a lot and and
then I jot notes as I think of them and
I like effortlessly came up with 50
questions without doing any of that
because this is such a fascinating topic
to me and I so deeply love animals like
especially dogs but like animals in
general and and and
like I cry for Cry For Dogs on Instagram
that I see that are you know like need
adoption and I don't know them right
like I I don't cry for people but I Cry
For Animals I I hear you I'm with you
yeah is there any meaning behind that
having such a deeper connection with
okay cool absolutely I feel the same way
in fact you know the the commercials
that come on with animals and rescues
and behind the cages and stuff you know
turn them off I can't see them and even
when I was in law enforcement it never
bothered me if a human was in trouble in
a certain way but if there if it was an
animal involved call I had to respond to
I couldn't do it I was a wreck so I do
feel that there is something in our past
in our energy in our DNA that connects
us so strongly to them that we have that
kind of reaction because it's it's
instant I'm just like you I have to look
the other way yeah it's like it's so
deep it's so and I avoid things like you
I don't watch the sad animal movies
there was some recent things that
happened with some pets and I was with
my mom and she was telling somebody
about I'm like honestly I can't hear you
talk about it Mom I it's like it's just
please be as brief as possible do you
get any information ever that maybe like
I was a dog like we were dogs in the
previous life or is there is there like
a con is there a closer lineage to being
you know one of them is that what it is
maybe or what's your gut intuition on
that or your read or your or your hit
right I think anything is possible
especially when it comes to a past life
you know there's no rule book out there
about what we did in our past lives or
what we could come into our new life as
whether we're human or animal coming
back as human or animal I don't think
there's I think any anything is possible
if it's in the highest and best good for
that particular Soul so perhaps for
people like you and I where that's our
you know our soft spot if you will
perhaps there is something there that we
experienced in a past life where we
could actually feel what it was like to
be that animal or you know have those
experiences that would make a whole lot
of sense to me and I I have no
explanation other than it's it's so
overwhelming at times
you can't even describe it you can't
Define it and and I relate to that on so
many different levels and I get
everybody's story about no this happened
to my dog or this happened to my cat and
I'm like
no I can't take it there was one story
and maybe this is something to do with
it too my most spiritual experience
ended up sort of happening through a dog
and it was in Tulum Mexico and for
people that have listened to the show a
lot they may have heard this story but
basically there was a dog the beach
there's lots of stranded dogs and there
was one that came around very like first
day we were on the beach and and it was
so cute and I just I just named this one
Lucy that's it it had a name from the
first day and I really wanted to see
Lucy all the time and when I would
release sort of that grip on wanting so
much all of a sudden she'd appear it'd
be like an energetic
experience and then day three day three
we went to Koba which was this m ruins
and we were walking around and there was
some stray dogs and I was
like I think I must have been a stray
dog in another life cuz one I feel like
I'm always hungry and two like I feel
for them so much and the loneliness and
then I made a comment about Lucy the dog
and I was like I feel like like Lucy's
me and the next day we went and did this
very long yoga yoga class and then had a
chakra balancing M Massage
went to the beach and my friend was on
her phone on the phone with her husband
and I was finding a spot down on the
beach and I was going to go to the other
side cuz we had been in the same bed
like every single day and there was no
sunlight so I just ended up migrating my
way all the way back to the original
place that we laid and as soon as I sat
down the dog sat next to me and I was
transported and I was had this out
ofbody experience where I I felt like I
I everything was love I got the
information like you're always loved it
was this overwhelming like like a one
with Source kind of feel like oh my God
love is like all there is and so I sort
of came back I don't know how long it
lasted but I bald and baled out of like
Joy like out of deep experience and I
later talked to another girl that is
very spiritual and and in tune with you
know sort of the the quantum field in a
in a strong way and she said said that
was your twin
flame and I was like oh so maybe like
the connection with animals is that we
are so closely like a part an aspect of
us like have you heard of twin flames
before yeah and and maybe that's maybe
that's it you know maybe it's because we
are living in a in that body and we are
having you know having the real
experience in such a close quarters kind
of way that it's an aspect of you maybe
I think that's a definite possibility
and also you know I got total Goosebumps
when you told me that story you said
being as as close to Source Dano this is
something that came to me so many times
during my communication sessions I never
experienced this with the Departed human
spirits that I connected with only the
Departed Animal Spirits they are so
close to source so yes that are the mo
they are the
purest
living
being to Source I never got that kind of
feeling you said that pure love thing
that you just it was just enveloped you
that for me has only come through with
animals I didn't find that to be true
when Departed humans came through and
that's so fascinating to me that you
experience something so similar to that
too that it was just all about that love
and that complete
enveloping amazing Indescribable feeling
that it was like the purest as close as
you get to source as possible so I I
totally relate to that and I also
believe in uh multiple universes
parallel universes so you know out in
the quantum realm of course we could be
having another lifetime another
experience in another dimension that
perhaps is what we're talking about here
that we are in a different kind of
physical body but maybe that's our
experience and that's why we're so moved
here in in this life in in this form
because we're having an experience at
the same time in another realm and
there's so many possibilities it just I
love this stuff were you very spiritual
before all this happened no okay that's
interesting no I was in the mortgage
business for like almost 20 years yeah
so wrong part of the brain but you know
I was doing you know the the corporate
thing I thought was the right thing to
do and I had a this wonderful career in
in the mortgage industry but I just it
just I kept getting in
trouble I got fired um every place I
ever worked at got was closed down or
they laid me off or whatever I was like
the who's who of who's no longer in the
mortgage industry so obviously the
universe was sending like this giant
sign hello Karen get out you're in the
wrong career so it was not at all that
course I never felt psychic I never felt
intuitive I had never had a psychic
reading I'd never even been to a psychic
fair or Expo or nothing I mean I was
completely just my love of animals is
what motivated me that I entered into
this crazy Journey so it has been a very
big Spiritual Awakening for for me so
that in and of itself is like hey if I
can do this anybody can do this you just
got to follow your heart and your
passion and do what you feel like you're
being called to do or hold or drawn to
how does the information come to
you um sometimes it's instant sometimes
it's like a a sense of a knowing like
I'll just know something about somebody
and and it'll come very easily just
depending on my state of mind other
times I have to really work at it have
to really focus and it may be an image
like a mini movie flashing across my if
you want to call it your Daydream kind
of mind just like right now if I told
you to think about the American flag you
you can picture it but you're still
looking at me you're still present but
you can see that American flag in your
mind so that's how sometimes the
messages come to me but I mainly train
myself to be able to hear the messages I
wanted to hear their voices and then lo
and behold it was usually in my voice so
here I wanted to hear them and it ends
up coming through sounding like me which
is really can be really confusing
because then you go well was that me or
was that them so and then sometimes it's
all of the above just kind of you get a
little bit of everything and you have to
connect the dots and figure out what it
means because it's not always like
talking to a human like for instance if
a a dog shows me that it's playing with
a red
ball it might not have one it might have
a blue ball or green ball or a yellow
ball or it may it maybe just it means a
toy it doesn't mean ball at all it's
just to get you to say it wants to play
so just because you see something it
doesn't necessarily mean that's exactly
what it is you have to try to figure
figure out what the animals are sharing
and uh you know you just never know what
they're going to come up with does it
happen all day every day or is it is
this sort of a tune in tune out thing uh
thank goodness
no I would never get anything done I
it's really a process and you know I
grew up with a Bewitched you know where
she would wiggle her nose and poof you
know and I Dream of Genie and in and out
and it's it's a lot there's a lot more
to it than that so for me I have to be
in work mode I have to be in you know
grounded I have to make sure that I'm
clear so that I don't bring any of my
thoughts feelings or whatever to a
communication session so I have to
really be mindful of myself and then I
mainly worked from a photo because I
like seeing their faces I I love animals
so I love seeing how cute they are but
that was my it was like having that
animal's cell phone number by looking at
that picture I could dial up their
energy it just made the connection a lot
simpler so it's a process and it doesn't
always happen instantly or you know you
won't be walking around and random
thoughts come to your mind all the time
sometimes yes but all the time no I was
at my dentist office one time in a um
she had a picture of her dog up on the
wall a big Mastiff like a 200b m
and I was making the appointment for the
next time I needed to come in and I
looked over at the dog and I said oh
what a beautiful dog and all of a sudden
I heard it say tell my mom I don't like
Daddy being gone so
much and I didn't say anything and I
thought so I asked her I said you know
is is there something about somebody not
changing their schedule or not being
around as often she said well yeah my
husband just started work as a
firefighter so he's gone now for two
weeks at a time and all of us are having
a hard time adjusting to it so you never
know what they may share with you or
what Pops
in what are the most common things that
they want to communicate and is it a
matter of like they'll usually I'm sure
somebody's asking for it right like
somebody's going I would love you to
like connect with you know this animal
what do they usually want to say are
there common themes there are and over
the years I've been doing this for a
long time it's kind of morphed into
afterlife
sessions where the clients would contact
me because they just wanted to make sure
that their beloved companion was first
of all okay um not alone not scared with
loved ones and here's a big one they
almost always wanted to know that they
either
understood why their mom or dad had to
end their life or that they weren't mad
at them for that or they didn't blame
them for that there's a lot of guilt and
remorse that we carry around I say we
because I'm guilty too I've done it so
that was a really big theme that I heard
all the time that they just wanted to
make sure that you know they they
understood you know we we make these
choices out of love and with their best
intentions as the number one priority
but it still feels so wrong I was just
having a conversation about this last
night and how you know for the most part
we euthanize like that's usually the
because they're suffering so much
because there's they need 24-hour care
they can't go to the bathroom or they go
to the bathroom too much or their legs
don't work or they won't eat or you know
and it seems like they send a pretty
strong
you know I've held two animals when
they've been put down and it's awful but
also the nicest thing you can do and
like you no matter what even in those
instances when you are you are sure you
know you you're doing it and you get
done and there's always a thought of
like did I do everything I could
have I know and
um I'm sorry I just lost one and
my I just had to go through this so it's
like right
there the wonderful thing to
realize is that the animals
never view it the way that we do they
see a completely different light than
how we do and what the things that keep
us awake at
night don't even matter to them like
it's it's a nonissue the things that we
struggle with and you know toss and turn
about and agonize over it's not even on
their
radar they won't even talk about it in
fact the one of the biggest like Lio
moments in my life was that how many
times I connected with a departed animal
and they didn't even want to talk about
their final
moments we
do because that's you know we're mom
we're Dad we we want to make sure we did
the right thing we need that validation
we need that but the animals are it it
doesn't matter to them the way it
matters to us and this is really
important
too what they have shared with me is
that we tend to focus on those last few
days few hours few minutes of their life
when they were in like the worst
condition they could possibly be in the
animals say to
me but that's not me what about all the
time we spent together what about all of
our memories what about all of the love
we shared they shift the focus to such
positive topics and we as the humans
always go toward oh my gosh I must have
done something wrong I missed a
medication I should have brought him in
sooner and the animals are like no I'm
good I'm here and you know we had a
great life together and there's
absolutely
zero of that kind kind of experience
from them from the animals they don't
take that with them in fact there's
three words that I say that the that are
not in the animals vocabulary of course
this is my experience and what I've
heard from them the three words that
they don't even
recognize
blame
guilt and
forgiveness they don't understand why we
beat ourselves
up why we're feeling so so badly about
what we've done because they can feel
the goodness in our hearts they feel
that intention that is the most P
powerful you know one of the things that
happened with that experience on the
beach was with a dog that it's like the
one sentence I left out of the
experience because I didn't think it was
important but you said it and I have to
makes me makes me have to recall it for
you which was that there was no need for
forgiveness because there was never a
judgment in the first place yes
absolutely
absolutely they they're not human and I
think we want to humanize them you know
I I do so I speak from experience but
they don't have the same experience that
we do as humans at least not when
they're in their their animal bodies and
having an animal existence so what we
focus on as like you said the Judgment
the guilt the grief hold
on just got to have this because it's
talking about
animals I know right I've got my tissue
right over here too it's
like and just because I do this doesn't
mean you know it's any easier for me and
I struggle just like everybody
else and blame myself and did I do
everything and oh my god do they are
they okay and so I go through all those
things too but you know we we have to
realize something and I write about this
in my book of course is that you the
only thing that matters is love and
sounds so corny and so cliche and
so
simple but that's that's really truly
what it comes down to everything comes
back to the love because they can feel
that what is in your heart they can feel
that and while it may not have ended the
way that we wanted you know perhaps you
know they went into crisis or you
weren't there to say goodbye or you were
there and they cried out in pain which
is
terrible an accident I mean there's so
many things that can go wrong but the
animals Focus solely and completely not
on what happened to them but on the
experience that they had with us because
it all comes back to they can feel our
love and that's all that really truly
matters um when
they like as an example my
brother-in-law accidentally
ran over their dog and killed him is
there sort of like an unfolding that's
predetermined in some way like that or
is it more just like look that happened
and don't worry about
it okay so this is a real touchy subject
because there are many who believe that
the animal chooses and the human chooses
their exact time of departure who's with
them who's not how it happens
all the way
down I haven't experienced that in
my ex my past sessions I have
experienced though that there is
a certain kind of I'll call it a
snowball effect that happens if the
animal's time is coming to an
end you might be able to save them or
alter or detour them a few times you
know whe whether you get them to the vet
in time whether you you know apply the
bandage you know
medication but ultimately once that
Domino has been knocked down there is
this kind of snowball thing that happens
and
eventually they're going to leave
somehow so I just haven't had a single
animal say to me yep I picked my time I
picked the place I waited until mom
wasn't here I haven't had that happen so
I can't say that with any
definitive you know solid evidence I'm
kind of an evidential medium I want
evidence I want proof I I follow you
know in police work if you don't have
evidence you don't have a case so I
follow the evidence that the animals Sur
and I just
can't say yes I think that there it's a
combination maybe on a higher level
things are supposed to happen and they
do but I've never met any
animal living or Departed who has wanted
their life to
end except under rare extreme situations
where they were in tremendous pain so
think about that no animal has ever
wanted their life to
end very different from human again I
dealt with a lot of suicides in the past
and you know humans make that choice the
animals no they want to live they have a
very strong will to survive and they
will do everything they can to take that
last breath to keep on moving to keep on
breathing it's very different from their
perspective so I I think that there's
probably something out there like in the
akashic records that says you know you
live to approximately this age or
approximately these things will
happen yes I do feel that that is
possible but I don't think any animal
sits down and says well I think today's
the
day that my life is going to end I just
I haven't had that happen and what's
interesting is that animals there's a
lot of euthanization that happens and
with people there's like none so meaning
like a person wants to be done and they
just have to wait it out and an animal's
like nah cool to just like gasp for it
you know like I'm just we'll crank out
whatever we can give get get here in
this life but it's like flip-flop you
know and I actually I actually believe
that humans should have the ability to
the right to die I I do it's you know
they've got a voice they've got a brain
they've got PE you know like it should
be your choice and I don't know why we
don't allow that to be honest especially
if you can you are the one sort of
essentially pulling the trigger on it
like it's really you just doing it then
and so it's interesting that they don't
none of them want to have life be over
with but there's plenty of humans that
do yep and I agree with you
wholeheartedly and I think it's also you
know I was just having this conversation
this morning you know we get to have we
get to help our animals transition
peacefully and I and I want to share
that this is so important
Danica if you're struggling there is
there is no right time okay I get asked
this all the time is there a right time
is there a wrong time to
euthanize no I mean there's so many
things coming into play but you know
your companion better than anyone so
what is your heart telling you if you
know that they're not themselves they're
not eating they're not drinking they're
not they're just that spark isn't there
you know you may not want to make that
decision but you know that it's time the
other thing I want to share is it's so
important that the animals don't go into
crisis mode so euthanasia I am
supportive of euthanasia when an animal
is in crisis mode and they leave their
body it's far more traumatic than when
they're peaceful and quiet and you're
calm and balanced as balanced as can be
I mean you know of course it I'm making
it sound really easy and it's not it's
horrible but if you can help your animal
transition before they go into crisis it
really is a blessing for them
and it helps them leave their body with
the same kind of dignity that they came
into the world with so that's what I
strive for I maybe I could have extended
their life another week another day
another month whatever it was but at
what cost what if they had gone into
crisis at two in the morning and I have
to drive to the vet office and I'm a
panic all over the place crazy
woman that's no good for anybody what
about the animals that get put down
because maybe they're
bad you know that's that's also very
interesting too because not one time
have I ever had a single animal even if
it was like a you know an aggressive
issue or you know perhaps
something Behavior Behavior will happen
they've never shown any kind
of wow I really messed up they don't
they don't take ownership of it they are
just very accepting like they're not
here anymore and they're fine in they're
continued after life so they don't go
back and kind of do a Life review and go
w i really messed up there I shouldn't
have done that you know back next time
I'll come back and switch positions and
be the one that you know gets bit
or they don't they don't do that they're
just accepting they're like well I'm not
here now I'm I'm in this for and they
move on
what about the ones that what about I
mean this just like this just
like things like that and also animals
that just get put down because there's
just too many of them hor too many of
them I mean that's just like an
overwhelming like I can't even I mean
it's
like I know which is
um why I started my nonprofit because I
have I I live on the top of a mountain
and I have 30 beautiful acres here it's
just gorgeous up in Eastern Washington
and I thought you know this is such a
beautiful place what can I do here to
help the animals so I found in my
nonprofit so I rescue the ones the pets
that no one else wants the ones that are
missing a limb missing an eye missing an
ear the the blind the old the deaf ones
the ones that have medical issues up the
wazo that nobody would ever adopt the
ones with no uh applications for
adoption those are the ones that I bring
here and they live out the rest of their
lives it's a final Refuge they stay here
with me as part of the family and I'm
their mom and this is where they
stay now if I could multiply that a
million times over for all the animals
out there that need it I would love to
but I hope I would Inspire one person to
also follow and do what I'm doing
because it matters and it's so important
because it's a tragedy and even those
animals as much as
as it hurts us I have never had anybody
come through to me animal wise and say
you know gee my life ended too soon or
you know I was just unwanted or I
couldn't get adopted or I didn't find a
home it's not like that they just accept
what has happened to them and again they
don't dwell they continue on their
spiritual journey and maybe the next
time around they'll be
better off or have a family or someone
to take care of them I can only hope
that but I think we can all do something
ourselves about that to help this huge
problem that we have with so many
unwanted animals in the shelters is just
heartbreaking at no fault of their own
yeah that's the tragedy you're doing
exactly what I've talked to for so long
which is I would go and get all the ones
that nobody wanted I would get the
oldest ones I would get the ones and I
would take them and I would have so many
pets so many animals and I would go
through the pain of losing them
constantly like that's if I had real
balls that's what I would do and if I
was actually a little bit of less high
maintenance life that's what I would do
in fact my sister just the other day
sent me a message she's like you should
probably have like a shelter or
something like that like it would be
called my bedroom right I um I have to
contr myself because I can only take on
so many because it's just me and my
husband here I don't have a staff or
crew or anybody coming in I'm head
pooper
scooper um I pick up
all I pick up all the unmentionables and
you know it's all it all comes back to
me but um it is my childhood dream come
true and I from as far back as I can
remember I was bringing home you know
the bird with the broken wing or you
know the the Stray puppy or whoever it
was do you follow dodo on Instagram dodo
yes dodo it's the only one I'll watch
because I know they make it yes Happy
Endings we like those happyend the only
one I'll watch
otherwise right it's like keep going
keep going keep going but yes it's um
you know it's to me I I can't save them
all I can't rescue them all but I can
save some and I can do some good for
them and I try to get the most tragic
cases possible I love that so it is a it
it's hard because I lose a lot and
that's why I'm just emotional about it
because I I real balls here I'm really I
admire you I honor you um thank you oh
that's a that's a that's a that's a
that's a constant emotional roller
coaster it is it's a it's a daily thing
we we deal with on a daily basis and
they're all precious to us and I have so
many that have made these incredible
Transformations and that's the other
thing I want to talk about I get the
ones no one else wants but they
transform themselves they can
actually not symptom with their issues
anymore once they are in that kind of
loving environment so please if anyone's
listening you know consider the ones
that are overlooked because they do
transform and it they if you raise the
bar for them and say you know I'm going
to give you a great home and love and
everything you could possibly want
you'll see some amazing Transformations
like I have too do you ever have any
like information about getting spited
and neutered and getting their balls cut
off and their you know do they is this
something that they don't like do they
ever comment like is this ever part of
their story because obviously it helps
keep control of things to some degree
but usually if they're getting that done
they're probably in a home where they're
probably not going to get knocked up
anyway is this a good practice that we
have
absolutely 99.9% of them could care less
don't mention it I had one poodle one
time tell me she wanted to have bab
puppies a litter one
poodle just one she wanted to have a
litter and she was not gonna be happy
until she had a litter so I've never had
any animal other than her come through
to me and say anything about that topic
you know because it's a surgery they're
out for the surgery so all they really
know is you know I'm kind of sore and oh
I'm feeling better and oh now I'm even
better and and then they move on so I
don't hear too much about that so if
anyone's wondering if they should do it
for the happiness of the animal it
doesn't doesn't matter kind of in the
same pathway of things that we do to
control things what about cages crates
leashes fences like
I mean look I've been yelled at so many
times for having my dogs off leash like
because and I'll put an electric collar
on them so like I have control right
because they are still an animal and
they still want to chase that squirrel
all the way to timbuk to um but I I do
have a control to some degree real good
electrocution actually um but but people
get uncomfortable with that but I feel
like they live inside of a house inside
of a fence on a leash like they just
want to run and be dogs and if you were
to ask me people ask me what is makes me
the happiest it would be to take my dogs
into the woods and watch them run like
to be able to see them just be dogs and
be so free like I can literally see them
smiling you know what do they have to
say about the sort of the control
mechanisms that we
use um absolutely everything that you're
saying there is an issue for them
because they just want to be who they
are and the more that you can honor that
the more that you can provide that kind
of environment for them where they can
live the best life for whatever their
breed is for whatever they are cat dog
horse bird you to be in the most natural
environment possible and keep them safe
of course keep others safe of course but
to be crated or to be leashed or to be
confined it is a frustration for them
and that's where I would see behavioral
problems develop so now there's some
like I had Chihuahua that she loved her
crate she didn't want to come out of her
crate she had a little bed in there and
her little blankets and I couldn't get
her to come out of there it's like Chloe
come on she's like no I am not leaving
my bed I mean she loved it in there so
there's always going to be an exception
to the rule but generally speaking try
to give your animal the most fulfilling
life that you can based on what they
want to do I also have another dog who
doesn't want to run he just wants Want
to Be Right By My Side so it it's kind
of specific toward the particular animal
too and I have cats that want to go
outside I have cats that never want to
step foot outside so you just kind of
have to play it by ear but you know I I
will say that the ones that are on you
know chained up their whole life or you
know confined in small areas of their
whole life okay you're killing me it's
it's like how would you feel if that was
you I mean put yourself in their shoes
and their skin and and live your life
that way I mean it's it's sickening and
and shame on anyone who's doing that and
you know I I have the benefit of having
um a very large space here for all of
our rescued animals to go out enjoy this
beautiful countryside that I live in
with apple trees and pear trees and
raspberries and flowers and I like it's
beautiful not everybody has that so do
the best you can try not to feel guilty
because there's that word don't feel
guilty about it if you're a dog person
this is so important so let's say you
have a a skittish dog nervous dog shy
dog fearful dog whatever you want to
call it so you let's say you have people
coming over to the
house you tell them ahead of time look
my dog is really fearful you know don't
don't look at her you know she's going
to run and high don't try to pet her by
doing that you are basically setting
that dog up for
failure because you're putting out it
into the universe this the The Voice the
intention behind it and the mental
images of your dog being fearful then
the person coming to your house has
those same thoughts so now all of those
thoughts converge onto your dog and your
dog's like I'm out of here and they're
gone so what I have learned and this
really works is is when you are in
alignment so your thoughts think about
what that dog looks like being
completely comfortable around people
friendly outgoing happy joyful to see
someone and visualize it so these are in
line what does that look like can you
visualize your dog being happy balanced
enjoying company say the words make sure
that you are talking to the dog about
what you want them to do not what you
don't want them to do and then feel it
in your heart you have to feel it this
is the big one here if you don't feel it
they're GNA get mixed messages and
you're going to confuse them so if all
of those things are in in alignment you
send a very clear message to your dog of
what you want from them and again you
raise the bar they will raise to that
level if you set the bar down really low
and expect them to be SC get us and
fearful and run off well guess what
you're going to have exactly
that so so try that it doesn't happen
overnight sometimes you might but it
really works you have to be mindful of
yourself especially if you live with
animals because whatever you're thinking
about them oh that's the dog that you
know is always always misbehaves while
we're going for walks well what did you
just do you just told that dog it's okay
to misbehave while you're going for
walks
we are so much more responsible for
their behavior than we realize because
we're their world we're everything to
them what about food real quick do they
like their dried kibble I see so many
health issues coming from the food that
were feeding them because it's basically
man-made so um to answer that question
they eat it do they love it some of them
do some of them don't is it the best
thing for them no it's not could we do
better yes we can absolutely do better
but I mean look at that stuff it looks
horrible it lives forever there's
something wrong with that I have two
dogs and Dallas is nine and I I did not
feed her like dry stuff like I've never
there's actually one week I was like
they'll live and I was taking a trip and
I was transitioning like where I lived
and certain things and they in
their kennel I never put them in the
kennel until that week they in
their kennel they got sick Ella about
tried to she's a Malin wash she tried to
bite her way out of the wire oh my God
it's the worst thing in the world so I
can't say I never have one week I tried
um but I cook their food because I I'm
like and I give them a little bit of
canned food but I cook most of it and
I've always thought that it just doesn't
make sense that it it doesn't really
expire barely and it's just like I don't
know like I remember one time I took a
bite of a treat that smelled that
smelled so good it was like vanilla and
cinnamon and I was like oh my God and I
was like I got to try this it tasted
like and I was like if this is what
a really good smelling treat tastes like
then dog food's terrible right I know
cat food's even worse too because oh wow
I know gross gross so
I hear you I think we could do better I
think you know the more natural of a
diet that you can feed dogs and cats the
better because look at horses I have
horses here too and you know they get
alphalpha and grass and pellets and it's
you know best if they're on what's
natural the grasses the haze that's the
best thing for them they develop all
kinds of health issues if I have to take
them off that natural food for whatever
reason so well the these dogs don't live
till 20 I've said maybe I won't cook
their food next time because the
Malinois can eat a lot of food like she
was skinny for a long time because I
couldn't wrap my head around just how
much food she needed I'm like surely
like eight cups of food a day six cups
of foods a day is enough but it wasn't
okay so personality very curious about
this because I have very two very
different dogs I have one that is well
the Malinois Ella she is High Strung on
alert she's my shadow I never have to go
to the bathroom alone she doesn't want
to leave me she might chase a rabbit for
a little bit but she's not going to
leave me and then and very anxious and
shakes all the time and runs circles
around me and then I have a miniature
Siberian
Husky and she I know I Debbie downed on
cats but I have love all animals I need
that to be known but she is something
between like a husky
a fox a cat and a wolf and she is like
bye and she doesn't I can I can beg her
to come sit on the couch with me or come
up on the bed in the morning I mean Ella
is literally like mauling my face and
I'll be like Dallas come here come on up
now and she and like I'll talk sweet to
her I'm like okay she's a person I'm
like Dallas come here and then I'll
start being like Dallas come here and I
can barely barely barely get her up on
the bed and I make her come up there and
I do what I she does what I call a
driveby she'll like drive by and I kind
of basically like pet her head and then
she turns around and takes off I'm like
fine I'll just take that I'm curious
about that about personalities with dogs
and sort of you know maybe first off
asking you know about like the
relationship between the owner and the
pet like that we'll start there and and
we'll go from there so um in what sense
did you mean though like do they mimic
us do they feed off of us like in what
sense were you how much of our how much
of our energy how much of our energy
becomes
theirs it I think quite a bit I think
sometimes some of them will pick up on
all of our
worst habits or behaviors and others
will pick up on some of our best so it
sounds like you have a little of each
you have some good balance there because
you've got you know Ella that's doing
this one thing and Dallas doing
something completely different Dallas
sounds like a total Siberian they are
like in a class all their own and and
like you said kind of catlike in a way
but I think we we really do have that
ability to rub off on them so to speak
or and they're able to pick up on on our
personalities they also in that same
breath they pick up on our health issues
so not not just personalities I can't
tell you how many times I've had a
session where I will connect with the
animal beforehand before I even get on
the phone with the client and I'll pick
up on like diabetes or maybe some other
kind of imbalance there are little
barometers so a good way to tell if your
if the animal is living in a balanced
home is I can almost always trace it
back to their behavior so if you
contacted me and said Karen I'm having a
problem with Ella you know she's all
over the place and oh my gosh she's this
and she's that well I would turn around
and say okay Danica what's going on at
home you know why is there this F
frantic energy going on maybe there's
some fuel being thrown on the fire that
you're not aware of that she's picking
up on and we can almost always trace it
back to something that is going on or
that you're not realizing is going on in
the household and that could be anything
you know job changing your jobs and you
know a relationship going south I mean
there's so many different things that
trigger them because they're literally
responding to our energy they're around
us all the time see they generally if
they do leave the house we we're with
them right we take them on walks or go
somewhere on vacation or you take your
pets I take mine with me not all of them
but so they're with us all the time so
of course they're going to reflect
what's going on with us in our lives so
if you're having a behavioral problem or
something weird is going on with your
animal I would say take a good look at
what's going on under your
roof what's happening there you know is
there something maybe that you don't
think is stressful but maybe the animals
who are 10,000 times more sensitive than
we are are picking up on that you can
adjust or shift or perhaps start
thinking differently about something we
don't have to make these big shifts I
want to be real clear about that too
sometimes it's just a slight change in
perspective just your expectations can
be a little bit different so I think
their personalities reflect Us in some
ways I think their their health issues
reflect Us in some ways and then some
fall into a category where none of that
applies you know there's always going to
be the exception to the rule but I think
a lot of times they do they're like
little sponges they absorb all of our
stuff are they here to teach us lessons
sometimes or is like that that part of a
purpose or or is it just purely
companionship I think that as far as
teaching us something I think that
they're here to help us experience more
so I like to look at it that way because
if I say well you know your your dogs
are here to teach you a lesson it sounds
like you're almost being punished for
something and you're not being punished
for something you're here to experience
as much as you can in this lifetime and
our animals are here here to enhance
that they're here to widen the playing
field they're here to bring in more
experiences so that we can get out of
our comfort zone or maybe have to
experience something that we wouldn't
have experienced if they weren't in our
lives I know I had a she was a
Rottweiler mastiff mix and this dog she
was so stubborn she used to just butt
heads with me every single thing I mean
even going for walks we struggled
through the whole walk and I was at one
point getting so frustrated with her and
I could tell she was frustrated with me
and all of a sudden I had this ping
light bulb went off of my head and I I
thought she's just reflecting back my
own
stubbornness that I'm just being so
hard-headed about everything I was
trying to control
her because I was controlling my own
life because I had just ended a
long-term relationship I was self
employed I had no other source of income
other than me and I was trying to
control everything and I realized whoa
this is what I have created and she's
picking up on it and she's just giving
back to me what I'm putting out there so
it was a a big quote unquote lesson for
me to stop and you know not try to
control things and be more
flexible of letting go of things I think
when we hold on too tightly
I think that at least for me that has a
real negative effect on the animals
around me we have to kind of let go of
the outcome we have to let go of the
outcome and just be like in the moment
with them right they're so in the moment
they're right here right now love me
love me love me right now or pay
attention to me or feed me or whatever
it is right now and I was doing the
opposite in my life so is that a lesson
perhaps I think more of it as a life
experience because nobody else could
have shown me what I was doing in that
moment except her so I think that's
really precious if you think about it so
yes they're with us to help us they're
they're here to soften the harsh reality
of Life they're here I know for me
anyways I went through a really tough
time I had everything came crashing down
on me and I was in a really bad Place
almost lost my house and I had two
neuros surgeries I couldn't talk so I
couldn't work I mean it was just
horrible and my animals were the only
thing that got me up in the morning
because I was feeling so overwhelmed and
so
defeated because of them I had to get up
I had to feed them I had to let them out
I had to take care of
them they saved me they got me through
that really really tough
time so is is that a
lesson I don't know I think
that's just a precious gift that they
bring to us in many ways even the ones
that drive you nuts I think you can
learn something from that experience why
did that drive you nuts is it a
reflection of you is it something that
you do and don't like in yourself and
not that you go around and pee on the
floor I don't mean that
but is there something going on I think
there's a lot to it even the ones that
are only with us for a short time you
know sometimes we think that we failed
because they were only here for a short
time this is the one other thing that I
think is fascinating you know as humans
we think the longer we live the better
right a a good life is a long
life and in the animal kingdom I haven't
found that necessarily to be true yes
they all want to live they all have the
desire to live but they're
more fulfilled by the quality of the
time that they're here rather than the
number of years so if you're if you're
struggling with an an older animal that
is maybe having a hard time and you
think you have to keep extending their
life to have a good long life for them
the animals really don't look at it that
way they would much rather be
able-bodied mobile healthy active and
and you know enjoying themselves as to
who they are in a shorter time
span than struggling and not able to
move around or enjoy who they are for a
longer life do they really struggle with
when they're like let's say you know you
have an animal and you're gone 9 to5
like do they struggle with the
loneliness and those those long hours of
like I think about the you know I've
probably left my dogs for sort of maybe
eight hours like maybe even 10 like a
couple times like twice but I think
about like the eight hour and I'm like
I've I've not done that very many times
but I'm like now some people go to work
every day and this is every day for
their animal you know I had one time I
was conducting a session and it was a
deceased dog and he kept showing me
computers like all I saw was a wall of
computers and I saw his human dad
basically glued to these computers and
when I conducted sessions way back when
there was no Zoom this was all done over
the phone so I never saw the client I
just talked to him on the phone and this
was this was even before the client
called me so I'm
seeing this man just being completely
glued to this basic wall of computer
screens all around him and I felt just
this Melancholy Feeling Just kind of
a this deep sense
of something missing there and the man
who I was doing the session for was not
very nice to me I told him what I was
seeing because he said you know what is
my dog want me to know and I I told him
what I was seeing and he never responded
he he didn't give me any feedback at all
but he was very quiet and the session
ended very abruptly and I heard back
from him several months later in an very
apologetic email that he was like you
know I didn't want to believe any of
this was
true but he said what you told me
really hit me he said because he spent
hours and hours and hours in his office
working on his computer with his dog in
the room with him and he said he never
gave the dog the time of day he was
there with him but he was so fixated on
his work and his computer
and he says I just want you to know
that I'm sorry I didn't respond but he
says you really helped me because I'm
not going to do that again he says I've
rescued another dog and I'm going to
make sure that I give this one all of my
attention and I'm going to balance my
work and I'm not going to be so you know
fixated on work and that was really
powerful to me because I hung up the
phone that day thinking God you know I
didn't accomplish anything here I didn't
help this man or the dog and then come
to find out it just took a while for him
to embrace that and go okay I can do
better so that's the beauty of the work
that I do it's sometimes it's not
instantaneous sometimes it takes a
little while for things to happen and
percolate up to where you're aware of
them you know how many of us get
distracted because is a family work
careers you know whatever we're doing in
our lives and then these little guys or
big guys or whoever we have around us
you know they're Here Wanting our
attention and our love all the time or
most of the time anyway mine are all
being really quiet right now which is
surprising
but but you know just get get down on
the floor with them you know get on
their
level be with them be present with them
just give them that time you know they
when they're gone they're gone you you
can you'll you'll have such a better
experience if you just spend that
one-on-one time with them now while you
have them while they're here how do we
know when they when they contact you
like how do you know like what are the
really strong what are the most common
ways that they will reach out afterwards
like as an example I always feel like
when I've lost one that I get a very
very Vivid dream very quickly after
within a couple of days and it like is
like feels like it's like a it's like a
check in from the other side like cool
Mom I'm good everything's cool like it's
very Vivid so in your experience how is
it that they try and comfort or reach
out to their owners after they've passed
number one way is through dreams and
it's always positive so if you have a
bad dream that's not visit that's your
subconscious working through different
scenarios and anxieties and there's all
kinds of things involved there I'm not a
dream expert but a a visitation from a
departed pet is always loving and real
and Vivid and you can feel them and you
can touch them and you know they're
there and when you wake up you're look
around because you're expecting to see
them because it was so real and that's
the the most common way that our
departed pets will connect with us and
sometimes they'll do it just one time
that we remember and other times they'll
keep visiting and keep visiting keep
visiting it's not a reflection of love
if it's only
once it's just simply that's all that
animal felt like it needed or maybe you
just don't remember the other visits
which is very possible too so the other
thing that they do is they will imprint
an impr print is kind of like that
Daydream that I was talking about
earlier where I said think of the
American
flag you'll be doing something usually
something mindless or folding laundry or
you know driving down a familiar Road
where you don't have to be
hyperfocused uh and in that kind of
mindless State you get in a rush or a
feeling or even a thought about them we
think that's our thought that's actually
a visit that's them coming in saying I'm
here I'm here I'm here I'm good I love
you and it's really powerful it can be a
surge of
emotions and you know may break down in
tears or it may make you really happy
you might have just any different kind
of response but imprinting is another
really common way and it's often brushed
off as just our own
thought but it's really them popping in
to say hey just stopping by to say hello
a lot of times I like to I believe and I
will share my opinion
that with Intuition or with feeling like
something happened or it's them or it's
a
sign the fact that you thought it was
them is
them it's not like don't make it any
more confusing than that it's like you
know if I see a dragonfly I know it's my
grandma like I just hi Grandma like it's
like
you know it's a if you think it's what
it is that is what it is right so for
everyone who's thinking you know oh I
want to get a session so if you had an
experience like you were saying and it
was so powerful and you're like was that
my dog or my cat coming through to me
just the fact that you are asking that
question yes it is you have to trust
trust so much of the work of of what I
do is based on trust I have to trust
what I get because that's what it's
built on that's what it's based on so
your brain already knows your higher
self already knows your intuition
already knows it's just your conscious
logical brain going ah that can't be
real oh that can't you know not so much
just lean into it and and isn't that
great that they wanted to stop by and
say hello to you and they love it when
we say their names out loud they love it
when we celebrate them in their silly
little Antics and and remember them on
holidays and birthdays and they love
that wouldn't you be thrilled if you
were on in the afterlife and somebody
thought about you and had just this
their heart just swelled up with love
with all the happy memories you would
love that you would flock to them like
oh they're thinking about me this is so
cool that's what our departed loved ones
do it's like a a celebration when we
think about them in a positive way it's
okay to grieve too that's
another something I wanted to mention
today you know we've kind of been
brought up in a scenario in this world
that grieving for a
pet is weird or you you shouldn't feel
that bad for a long time or you know
it's just a pet go get another
one and and that's so sad to me because
it's a loss just like any other loss and
you have a right to grieve you should
honor those feelings you should
absolutely be given the time and the
space to grieve for your pet and I'm a
very private
griever I don't want anyone to know I
just disappear I become a Hermit and I
don't talk about it I just want to glom
on to my animals and I just want to be
alone but that's just me you know if if
it makes you feel better to go out and
and volunteer or help another animal in
need or to go to a group setting and
talk about it in a group setting do that
I I want to take the weirdness out of
grieving for a pet it it shouldn't be
weird it should be absolutely normal
what about when there's one that you
just like you can't let go of there's no
moving on from it when there's such a
deep deep attachment to that have the
animals ever conveyed information that
they that that there's that there needs
to somewhat be an expiration on that and
that you know kind of like you know when
a person passes they're like oh your dad
would want you to be happy or like you
know something like that you know or
you're a a partner passes on for some
reason and you're not sure if you should
move on like they would want you to be
happy it's like you know is this is
there is there a point in time where
it's just too much though yes and uh let
me
explain yes
because they they love you and they want
you to be happy and they're afterlife
experience is really fueled by you your
loving thoughts and the energy that
you're putting out there when you grieve
your energy is
low just natural when you're happy and
joyful your energy is
high so if your departed pets in the
afterlife rely on you as fuel for their
afterlife experience when your energy is
low therefore their energy is low they
can't gain any more fuel from you
because you're low that's when you're
grieving when you're sad when you're
upset when you're sick all of those are
low vibrational energies so it's only
natural plus you're no fun to be around
when you're like
that it's only natural that when you're
more fun to be around you're happy
you're smiling you're loving life you're
thinking of them with a smile on your
face and oh my God the things that they
used to do that gives them more energy
because that is a higher vibration so
they're able to gain more energy off you
which means that they can send you more
signs more messages from the afterlife
they can be more upbeat and more
positive and you're you're not it's you
don't want to be you have that person in
your life that's always negative there's
that one person that you know they they
never have anything positive to say and
they're complaining or gossiping or you
know everything is just negative they're
no fun to be
around they always have some kind of
drama in their lives no no one wants to
be around that your animals don't want
to be around that either it's not saying
that your grief will ever harm them
because it
won't but if you just remember that
there is a a time where your animals are
going to start to think gosh every time
my mom thinks about me or my dad thinks
about me they get sad I mean when you
start to get a little bit of a complex
like am I making them sad is the thought
of me making them sad so they don't
understand necessarily the big concept
of grief that goes on for a long period
of time they they understand when we're
happy they understand when we're sad so
after a while just like anything else
you start to get a little bit like God
I'm making them this sad every time they
think of me they start crying so there's
a little bit of both going on there are
they part of a soul family then is it
like a soul family situation where
there's sort of like a almost like an
energy cluster to the group yep so when
I would conduct a session I would be
sitting right here in my office I have
this um off camera to my left is where
the spirits would appear to me human and
animals sometimes they'd be partial form
sometimes they'd be transparent
sometimes they'd be I couldn't even see
them I could just hear them or sense
them I just never knew what was going to
happen and Dano the coolest part was
when I brought in animals energy through
the animals always came through boom
just like that it was the human energies
that would
hesitate the animal energies are always
like I'm here I can't wait to talk I
can't wait to share and the human
energies were like I don't know about
this kind of scrutinizing me right so I
find that really fascinating but the
animals would almost always come through
with a human family member a mom a dad a
grandma Grandpa brother sister Uncle
cousin and it doesn't have to be blood
relative it could be a best friend from
Junior High it could be you know the
elementary school cring maybe the animal
never met them but you know both of them
you the idea of a soul family like it's
like oh no don't trust me up here we're
homies we're all homies right so because
you're the common denominator they come
through together and then I would hear
this I would tell the client oh I your
grandmother's here she's holding your
dog or your cat and theyd go well
Grandma hated animals you know she
wouldn't be holding a dog or a cat she
hated
animals okay maybe in life she hated
animals but you see when you are in the
afterlife there's so much love that just
infuses you that things like that that
you didn't really care for in the
physical world that kind of dissipates
because it's you're just pure love you
know it's just such a beautiful
experience in the afterlife so they
missed the whole idea that Grandma's
coming through with their dog or their
cat to say hey we're all together in
this big soul group because they're
stuck on the physicality of when Grandma
was here and you have to let that go let
it go so then we see our pets then when
we die then too yes absolutely even if
like I get a little stumped on this one
because of the whole I I believe in
reincarnation and so how is it that we
see imagining that you know some day
when I pass it will have been a long
time since I lost my pets and assuming
they might have
reincarnated or not like I mean why 70
years later am I like there's Pete you
know like did he not reincarnate or is
it what what what allows that o
opportunity to see them again I think
and this is this is really a challenge
for me because the evidential cop Karen
wants to say say you know everything has
to fit into a box and evidence has to
prove that this is what happens and
reincarnation is really thinking outside
that box I don't think that there is any
set rule book that says that you have to
experience X Y and Z when you
reincarnate and I don't think there's
any set time frame so I think when a
soul reincarnates
it could be a hundred years later 40
years later after you pass away it could
be 500 years later I don't know
that we have to be with each other at
the same
time when we pass away does that make
sense to you I don't know that we all
that all of our beloved pets are going
to be there waiting for us at that same
moment in time because there's no time
in in the afterlife so I struggle with
that I know it does get a bit confusing
with like timelines I mean the one the
only thing that makes sense to me is is
that you know they say that every
decision is a split of a timeline and so
there's sort of infinite timelines
happening and so you know when you pass
you can be in a timeline with a remnant
of something like there's just sort of
like the the the timeline continues of
like oh in this timeline I'm in my dog
is dead so I'm going to see it in heaven
right like or in the afterlife and and
so but there's so many other timelines
happening right there's a timeline where
it's kept living for a while there's a
timeline I died earlier there's timeline
you died earlier but in that one this is
the way my life looks and so you are
able to access what's in that timeline
right and I firmly believe that you're
so right on there and I firmly believe
that when you and I make that Journey
and we're in the afterlife we'll either
know all the reasons why or it won't
matter yeah it's probably not going to
matter just probably not because we'll
be like why did we even care about that
I mean yeah I struggle I totally believe
in reincarnation but I struggle
sometimes with trying to make logical
sense out of it because I don't know
that you can it'll happen the way it's
supposed to happen and we'll be
surrounded by those that we're supposed
to be surrounded by and like I said
maybe when we get there we'll go
I don't know why I worried about this
because or wondered about this because
it's all perfect eating
animals now look I've gone round and
round and round okay I didn't for a
while and then it was fish and then it
was and like look I just it feels better
like steak makes me feel better Pro like
chicken like salmon you know like that
makes me feel better and so do you have
any feedback on like what the experience
is like for have any animals
communicated that and I went down a
rabbit hole and I allowed myself to
watch Slaughter Slaughter videos and I
felt so bad and I thought man if I go
buy it in the store I'm just
contributing to it and so like I'm
trying to drop demand it led to health
issues it led I mean you show me a vegan
that's healthy after 10 years of not
eating meat and I will be
shocked so everything that you say I
have experienced to some degree or
another um I went from
eating animal proteins to not to
vegetarian to vegan and here's what I
can tell you is as I mentioned earlier I
haven't met a single animal that wanted
to die the majority of my work is
companion animals so I didn't do a lot
of work with Factory farmed animals I
think part of that was to protect
me and to feel good about my
choices at the
time and the bottom line I think is you
have to first of all not judge anyone I
don't judge anyone because I don't like
being judged so I will not judge anyone
based on their choices of of what they
choose and you just have to find what
works for
you and for me that might be different I
am
about 97%
plant-based I raise my own hens I don't
have a rooster but I raise H and so we
have their eggs and then I also do
locally sourced honey and and that's
just my choice right now but there are
some people like you're were saying that
have um you know Health situations that
they need certain things in their diet
and I think you just have to be at peace
with that or at least Source your food
food
wisely make good choices you know know
where it's coming from know how it's
raised know what is it's being fed you
know I can't I will not allow myself to
judge you or anyone because it's not my
place and we have to bottom line do
what's best for us but you don't know if
like the animals have said don't eat me
or or I'm good with it or anything you
just know that no none of them want to
die um and they just want to have a good
life so essentially if we could come up
with some sort of structure where cuz
look they can be honored too like they
could be revered many many many moons
ago they were killed and every piece of
them was honored there was ceremony
around it they wore them like nothing
was left behind so there could be like
really beautiful ways of of of of
honoring the path of that life if it's
we're talking about a good life it's
definitely not not a factory farmed life
yeah you know it's it's a terrible
reality that many people don't even want
to hear about and I've watched all those
documentaries too and it's horrific so
again just making wise choices as a
consumer even with other products you
know just your day-to-day products in
life I think we all have to be more
aware cruelty-free you know why are we
still testing on animals why you know
why are there fur Farms you know we
could go down that road Rabbit Hole too
but I think what it comes down to is you
as the
individual you know make a wise informed
decision and and be aware you know
information is powerful and educating
yourself about the choices that you're
making you can apply that to any aspect
of your life and be a better person
because of it and you know if it works
for you to have a certain type of diet
you know you have to be at peace with
that you have to come to terms with that
and like you said be grateful be
thankful and and all of those things
that go with it and and and really at
the end of the day it's a personal
choice just like you chose the path that
you chosen the the path L traveled um I
also I chose a path weirdly Less
Traveled but sometimes those are the
most rewarding those past L traveled you
have to be able to be okay with the
choices that you've made and and feel
good when you look back on it going you
know
what that was really hard and it was the
biggest challenge I could have ever
faced but boy I'm glad I did it I'm
really glad I did it and you know can I
make better choices in the future yes
but I'm okay with where I am right now
thank you so much I feel like you've
given so much comfort to those who get
afraid that they've done the wrong thing
or they you know know they don't know if
they did a good job and like just to
love on their dog and do your best and
that basically they they know your truth
which is did you love them or not when
it blows me away that says something and
um one message can be so powerful so I
had a client call me she was uh
devastated because she had backed over
her cat on the way out of the garage she
was late for work she had to get to a
meeting and she was rushing she didn't
look and the cat was there now the cat
survived that initial injury but
eventually it succumbed to its injuries
and it didn't make it passed away so she
contacted me to reach out to the cat
just because she felt horrible and you
know tell them I'm so sorry and she was
mortified they had really bonded he was
as stray and she took him in and and he
was like the love of her life and just
this really cool cat
and I'm on the phone with her and as I'm
talking to her the whole time that we're
on the phone the cat kept showing
me an amputated
leg now it wasn't like a gross you know
visual or anything it just looked like a
human leg that had had been amputated
there wasn't like it wasn't bloody or
gross or anything like that almost
looked like a doll leg but she was so
upset that I didn't want to add more
trauma to her so I didn't want to
mention it because I figured the cat had
lost its leg in the
accident so I didn't say anything three
times the cat kept showing me this image
and I have a rule that if the animals
show me something three times that I
will say it because it's important and
that means I must say it so I told my
client I'm really sorry to do this I
know that you're really struggling here
I said
but did your cat lose a leg in that
accident and she got really
quiet and then she started
sobbing like hysterical sobbing I
thought oh man I've really screwed up
you know I just m took a situation made
it even worse and made her feel even
worse I shouldn't have said it I
shouldn't have said it and I so I
started POS I'm so sorry I'm so sorry
she's like no no no you don't understand
this was the best thing you could have
told
me she said no no you don't understand
she
said 3 months after he passed away I was
in a horrible car accident and my leg
was
amputated and while I was recovering I
could feel him in the bed with me next
to where my amputated leg
be they still don't leave they're still
there oh wow wow what a strong
connection too for them to be able to
feel it for the pet to still be there
and for the for for the owner to still
feel it like such a like the pet showed
up in a big way he was more concerned
about her recovery never said anything
about the accident that he had been
through he could care less about that
remember I told you it just doesn't
matter right right and and
essentially she drove over him so like
like no it's still laying by laying by
her side it was more concerned about her
recovery and being there for her when
she needed him the most I mean that
story is so powerful and so moving and
it blew me away so much because it was
not at all what I thought it was and
then it turned out to be this
incredible I
mean God yeah how important that it just
like I what the big takeaway is just the
animal knows your intention it knows
your heart you can lie with your words
you can lie to your you can lie to your
friends you can say things that you you
can you can try and try and convince
yourself but like of something but it's
like your heart is the truth and and
then they know your heart I mean you
might be able to you might even do all
the right things but just kind of not
really give a about the animal and
it's going to think I it didn't really
give a even though it had a you
know mansion in the hills and you know
people taking care of it all the time
and fancy food and but if it's like the
owner didn't really care that's exactly
what it
feels they can see who we are they can
feel who we really are in our heart and
those of us who love our animals we have
nothing to worry about because they know
what our intention and they know what's
in our heart sometimes I think some of
the happiest animals in the world might
end up being like homeless people's
animals because that's all they got like
I imagine that they'd feed the dog or
the cat or the animal before themselves
and I just want to I just want to say
something you are amazing I am so
grateful to you not only for being able
to be a guest on your show but just the
inspiration that you are to women and
young people and I admire you so much
and thank you for taking The Road Less
Traveled and for being that that Beacon
for us but also this show that we just
did your um
authenticity I could feel you were in it
you were in it and I appreciate that so
much because not everybody is and and I
can really feel that you are in it and
I'm just very grateful to you and I I
really really appreciate you and I just
want to share that with you oh well
that's uh thank you thank you and I can
absolutely sense how deep your love is
for Animals because the the words and
the emotion match right where I'm at and
I know how I feel so you know again
thank you for being the one with the
balls that's willing to go get all the
animals that need a home that are too
old or ugly or or messed up or yes sick
for for a for a good home it's like yes
I uh I I'll uh you'll have to you'll
have to pay attention at some point in
time in the future that will be me but
it's not me right now but I will do that
well I'll be here if you have any
questions and I hope you got that copy
of the book that I I got them
all yay thank you so much I mean how
cool I've been flipping through I
haven't read all of them I flipped
through some of them and read some bits
and what amazing collection of
information and there's basically a
question to I probably could have
literally just consulted with the books
I'm sure and not talked to you but it's
far better to hear from you I appreciate
you so much Danica thank you this is
like I'm gonna check a box today that
this was like such a dream come true for
me today so God well thank youon I'm so
grateful for you thank you for giving us
so much comfort really thank you thanks
everybody for listening to the pretty
intense podcast today I hope you enjoyed
it if you like what you heard today and
you want to hear more please click on
the Subscribe button